después de pasar la inspección esta
mañana de los inspectores de rusia
ucrania y los mediadores de turquía y
naciones unidas el buque transatlántico
razón y ya está transitando en la ciudad
de estambul y el estrecho del bósforo
con grano y cereales ucranianos que ha
sido el primer barco que sale de ucrania
tras la invasión rusa en febrero de este
año el raso lista transitando el bósforo
en dirección primero al mediterráneo y
después al puerto de trípoli en el
líbano donde podrá descargar sus 26 mil
toneladas de trigo crearon el primer
barco que sale de ucrania como decíamos
desde la invasión es un tránsito muy
importante que atravesado primero el mar
negro llegará hasta trípoli se espera
que dentro de unos 34 días con su cargo
muy importante decíamos porque es el
primero que sale y se espera que si este
tren de tránsito es seguro y efectivo
puedan salir durante las próximas
semanas muchos más barcos como este
desde ucrania destino a otros países del
mundo muy necesitados de cereales y
granos por la grave crisis alimentaria
global por los altos precios de este
producto alimentario